Let's look at specifically for live hacking events.
So, you know, you mentioned that you're focusing on high and critical bugs and on live hacking
events, you don't get to pick your target, right?
Which I understand you're normally pretty picky about because you have a specific set
of a very particular set of skills.
I was going to say if you weren't.
Yeah, exactly.
What's up, y'all?
We've got an excellent episode for you today.
Our guest is Alex Chapman, a bug bounty hunter renowned for his critical vulnerabilities
at live hacking events and his extremely, extremely detailed reports.
We talked to him about everything ranging from his red teaming experience to how to be a
full-time bug bounty hunter to how to find these crazy vulns.
And I think you're really going to enjoy the episode.
But before we dive in, I want to remind you to head over to ctvb.show and drop your email
there.
We're trying to grow that newsletter so that we can stay in touch with you all and so that
you don't miss an episode.
Without further ado, Alex Chapman.
Alex, thanks for coming on the pod, dude.
Hey, how are you doing?
Pretty great, dude.
This is going to be a really cool episode.
I think I've admired your hacking from afar and from close at a bug collision in January.
And so I'm excited this time to pick your brain and kind of get some of those techniques out
of you.
I was hoping we could start today a little bit with a little bit of your infosec history
and kind of talk to us about how the hacker that is now AJX Chapman has evolved to where
he is today.
Yeah, sure.
So I guess I'm a bit of an old timer, certainly in the bug bandy club.
I've been doing professional security for, I guess, must be at least 16 years by now.
Wow.
Kind of started straight out of university professionally.
I had interest from when I was about 12, 13.
And as soon as I could learn to program.
That's the age, man.
Yeah.
As soon as I could learn to program, I kind of wanted to know how to break things.
There wasn't as much information around back then.
So I kind of had to scrape pieces together from here and there.
And then kind of decided it'd be a good idea to do it.
Can you give a science degree, as you do?
Mm-hmm.
Hated it.
Absolutely hated it.
Yep.
Relatable.
But then found out towards the end of my degree.
Yeah.
Relatable.
For sure.
But then at one point, we had a guest lecture from somebody who worked for one of the big four, who was a pen tester.
I was like, you can actually get paid to do this sort of thing.
So from then on, that was my goal.
Straight out of the university, I was into big four because I knew they did pen testing.
Right.
Now, when you say big four, are you talking about big four accounting firms?
Is that what you're talking about?
Yeah.
So I went to work for Delight.
Okay.
Sure.
And in there, specifically in their security team.
Mm-hmm.
And was doing pen testing from then on.
So I did about, I don't know, a decade of pen testing, three years at Delight.
Moved to a smaller consultancy.
And that's where I picked up kind of red teaming and security research.
Knew nothing about bug bounty at this point.
So this was going back to, I don't know, maybe 2016, 2017.
Okay.
All right.
And then went to work for Yahoo.
Nice, man.
I feel like a lot of good hackers kind of go through Yahoo at some point.
I don't know if it's just like the time period of like, you know, Yahoo was a big name earlier
on in the bug bounty scene or in the pen testing scene.
Yeah, hugely.
You know, I feel like I see so many people that have gone through there.
So I've got a couple of questions for you.
You know, you mentioned that you started programming early on.
You know, was that out of, but you didn't really get introduced to hacking until later.
Is that right?
Or were you studying programming that whole time?
Or was there a little bit of hacking in the youth as well?
Or certainly a little bit of hacking.
Yeah.
So kind of looking at war games and.
Oh, sure.
Sure.
Kind of crack knees.
Crack me.de used to exist.
Oh, yeah.
Pretty sure that's been dead for a long time.
Crack me.de.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's still a thing.
It was.
So.
So kind of.
Interesting.
A lot of reverse engineering.
Huh.
Specifically on crack knees.
So a legal outlet for trying to learn these skills.
Gotcha.
So it was in college where you were introduced to being able to do this as a job.
But that's what you were saying.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I never in kind of a million years when I was in my early teens, I thought I could get paid to do this.
And then just had this epiphany moment.
I was like, I can do this.
Yeah.
So that was my mission from then on.
Yeah, dude.
That's awesome.
That's so cool.
I sort of remember.
I remember that moment for me as well.
Being like, wow, you know, this is actually a career path that I can go down, which is really cool.
Because at the same, you know, I started when I was young as well at 12 or 13.
And I kind of went down the blackout route for a while.
And I was like, but then I sort of caught a conscience.
You know, I was like, oh, actually, this is really damaging systems that I'm working on trying to cover my tracks.
Because I wasn't necessarily good enough to really do a good job of covering my tracks.
So my track coverings was, you know, RM-RF slash, you know.
And so, you know, that's kind of when I pivoted off.
And then, you know, coming into that realization that it can actually be a career.
Man, what a mind-boggling thing.
So you mentioned, you know, you were in CS, but you weren't loving that.
Why?
What is your opinion on, you know, should aspiring hackers go and get a degree versus going, you know, training themselves or going through boot camp or what?
I think my personal opinion from kind of where we are now in 2023 is I wouldn't bother.
Yeah.
I would apply yourself, learn to program.
I think all hackers should know how to program, at least basically.
I know that's a bit of a controversial opinion in some circles.
Yep.
But my view on it is you shouldn't have had a program.
Or you should be interested in learning how to program.
Sure.
Let's say it like that.
And just apply yourself.
Blog a lot.
Blog about everything you can.
So I actually used to do hiring.
And that would be the first thing I would do.
If a CV passed screening, I would look a person up on Twitter, try and find their blog and see what they were interested in.
Yeah.
And people who didn't have blogs would actually be in.
I know I'd have to drill them a lot more in an interview to try and work out what their passion is and what they're interested in.
And again, you can make money in bug bounty.
You're not going to start out and make the big bucks, but you can get by and you can, again, build up an effective CV saying, yep, I hacked this company by this bug, this company by this bug.
And to me, that's much more impressive these days than somebody who came out of a degree spending all their money to get a bit of paper who actually has next to no real world experience.
Yeah.
Yeah, I found that to be very true.
I also dropped out of college.
And like, I mean, when I went into college, I was kind of doing some hacking adjacent stuff, like stuff that I think now would be considered under the realm of like bug bounty slash general infosec hacking.
And I think that precursor knowledge really helped me find the path that I was looking for.
I had already been very interested in like programming and computers and that kind of stuff.
And so once I'd seen like this was a route that could be taken and it was like profitable and it was like very interesting and it was very in line with the stuff that I was already doing and already found a lot of enjoyment with, it just seemed like a very natural progression.
I'm curious, like how far you sort of deviated from what you would consider, like what you were already doing to pivot into bug bounty or was it kind of that same natural progression?
Sorry, going from pen testing and red teaming to bug bounty?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So yeah, I mean, it's actually going from more of an audit and test side of things to bug bounty is a huge world of difference.
But when in the kind of audit space with security, you're reporting absolutely everything and looking for absolutely everything.
So you're reporting SSL ciphers and all the stuff that nobody cares about, has no real impact.
But if you don't report it and the client kind of finds out about it, you can get into real trouble.
And so that's the kind of soul destroying end of pen testing.
But then on the red teaming side, I actually got a lot more experience that would be more relatable to bug bounty.
And that's kind of actually trying to find and properly exploit bugs in anger, see how far you can get with them and what you can actually do with it.
So the bug's no longer theoretical or something popped up on a scanner, you know 100% that it's there and it can be exploited for this sort of impact.
And that, I think, was a big learning point for me was actually not just CVSS impact, but real world impact.
Yeah.
So your scanner says this is a 7.2, so it's obviously high.
But what does that actually give you access to?
Does the business care about this thing?
Or is it actually a third party bit of software or third party hosted thing that means nothing to them?
Yeah.
And it's things like that.
If you can kind of start to bring that experience into the bug bounty side of things, you'll find you get a lot further as well.
Yeah.
Did you find that your time at companies were really helpful for figuring out that sort of security impact?
Because this is something that we've talked about a lot.
It's like CVSS versus direct impact and understanding security model of a company.
And instead of framing your bug so that you have a 9.0 CVSS, that's good and stuff.
But it really matters more.
What's the actual impact?
How does this affect the company?
How can you frame this so that the company sees the impact the same way that you do?
And do you think that your time at companies and all the red teaming and stuff really helped with that?
Yeah.
Huge.
And that's also, I guess, on the report writing side of things as well.
Because red teaming, we used to write kind of 96, 150 page reports.
Wow.
So when I first started doing bug bounty, I would probably take four hours of each report I was writing.
Oh, wow.
And that would be, even some basic XSS reports would take me several hours to write.
Jeez.
Because I was getting into that level of detail.
Okay.
That was overkill.
Yeah.
But there's still kind of Douglas Day working with him quite a lot.
And he still takes a piss out of me for how much I write in reports and how long it takes me to write a report.
It's really funny.
I still like to get that.
Yeah.
It's funny because I used to do the same thing where I would go very, very in-depth.
I would give them a full explanation of how does this work?
What is this doing in the back end?
And at a certain point, I realized I was like, wait a second.
I'm explaining to these engineers how their own systems work.
They don't really need to.
For me, this is satisfying.
But for them, it's like, okay, skip, skip, skip, skip.
Oh, there's the vulnerability.
Yeah.
And that's how it fixes it.
I think also for us as hackers, it's a fun narrative to convey.
It's huge.
I found, especially on reports that I'm really proud of, I'll go above and beyond on the, or at least on the bugs that I'm really proud of.
I go above and beyond on the report because I'm like, I want you to understand what a masterpiece this is.
Yes.
Like, you know.
100%.
It's when you get the reaction from the program team being like, wow.
Yeah.
That's nearly worth any bounty.
So satisfying.
Yeah.
And I bet, I bet, I bet you get that a lot, Alex, because, you know.
It does certainly happen.
Yeah.
And, and the fact that you acknowledge it definitely means that it happens a lot.
You know, because I've been privy to some of the reports that you've, you've, you've found it specifically at the GitHub event last year.
Just what a phenomenal performance that was.
Yeah.
So.
That was a great day.
Wasn't it?
Yes.
That was a good day for me.
Cool.
I believe it, man.
I believe it.
Um, so I'll, we'll talk a little bit more about that later, but I wanted to come back to what you said earlier about, um, you know, hackers should, should be able to program or should have an interest in learning programming or should have an interest in programming.
Um, could you speak to a little bit about how that, uh, just speak to that for our listeners and also, um, how, how that integrates with your style of hacking, which is different than most others, I believe.
Yeah.
And that's, that's a really good, um, good question.
I was reflecting on this a little bit earlier.
Um, I spend a significant portion of my time hacking in an IDE.
Mm.
And go trying to find issues and learn basically how a module works or how the server works that they're doing or how the protocol works that they're communicating with.
Right.
And without being a program, that would be next to impossible.
And that's very specific to my, my style of hunting.
But if you really want to, in my opinion, if you really want to be able to understand the bug, you need to know how, how it was implemented.
What assumptions a programmer would have made to, to introduce that bug.
And ideally how to fix it.
Mm.
So if you know, if you know those three things, you can really hammer home what a bug is.
And, um, and start to understand where you might find it in other places as well.
It's all very well kind of spraying payloads all over a website.
But if you don't really understand what's going on in the back end and what's happening to those payloads, then what's the point?
Yeah.
Blimey throwing darts.
That's a really good point.
I was actually just talking with, um, one of my buddies who's just starting to like get into bug bounty and, and security and that kind of stuff.
And he was going through the port swigger web economy.
And he was telling me today that like, he's now at a point where he can, if he looks at a vulnerability, he can like 80% of the time figure out what's going on just by like sussing it out and like doing a little fiddling with it.
And I think that is so key to really making progress in bug bounty and hacking as a whole, but especially bug bounty, just because it takes that level of understanding of like what's actually going wrong here.
How does this bug interact with other systems?
What are the different possibilities for me to move laterally or vertically within this vulnerability to escalated or to do X, Y, Z?
And if you don't have that, then it's really just like throwing darts like blindly at the wall and just like seeing what sticks and just like hoping for the best.
Yeah.
I'll, I'll speak, I'll speak briefly to our audience here as well.
Like this is another great example of something that we talk about really often, which is, um, you know, you don't have to know programming to hack, but if you do know programming, you will find substantially better bugs because you'll understand at a deeper level what is happening.
And what, um, you know, you'll be able to understand the exploits that are occurring and you'll be able to go for things that are a little bit deeper.
Most of the bugs that Alex submits, um, statistically even are, are between high and crit, right?
And on the crit side of, of, you know, between high and crit looking from his hacker one impact, right?
He's, he's got a, uh, what is it?
32.7, um, impact on, on hacker one, which is phenomenal.
Um, and, and so, uh, you know, this is just to, just to be clear, you know, we, we don't, we don't, we won't say that you have to know how to program to hack, but if you, if you do, you will gain a much greater ability to find critical bugs.
So that's a, that's a great takeaway.
Um, and, um, Alex, bringing it back around to your, your sort of personal infosec history, you, you worked at Yahoo slash Oath slash whatever the heck they want to call it in Verizon Media, you know?
Yeah, it was, it was an interesting time.
Yeah.
Could you, could you speak to a little bit about that experience?
What were you, what were you doing there and what kind of things did you learn?
So, yeah, so I was on their internal red team there.
Um, so that was, we were kind of every month or so, be given a, uh, an objective.
Um, and more often than not, it would be try and get access to the CISO's email, um, and show how we could do that with, with internal knowledge.
Um, but we used to have a, with the, with the issues that, um, kind of the IO had had previously, there was always an assumption internally that, um, internal access would be relatively easy to obtain from an attacker's perspective.
Mm.
So we, we would kind of go from that, um, that position of being an attacker with internal access and see what we could do in the internal network.
And then obviously work with the various teams to, to get that fixed and, and see what other kind of defense in depth we could, we could help to, uh, to implement that.
Mm.
So you mentioned that.
How much of your.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
So you mentioned that a lot of the hacking that you do is like in an IDE, it's looking at source code, it's looking at how stuff works.
Um, has that always kind of been the case for you just based on your background or did you sort of pivot into that style of hacking after doing a lot of, you know, black box testing and all that kind of stuff and just sort of figuring out that this was what you liked the most, or this was what worked the best for you.
Yeah.
So, I mean, that's always been my area of interest, um, and actually kind of going even lower down the stack into reverse engineering and, and, uh, and debugging, um, and kind of binary exploitation as well.
That, that was always my first kind of my first infosec love, uh, as it were, but there was very little opportunity to do that whilst doing kind of the audit stuff and testing that I started out doing.
Um, so I remember for kind of months I'd be sitting in a data center with no internet connectivity, um, running in map against kind of a billion and one servers.
Oh man.
Um, but I use that time to kind of read, read off on man pages in, in Linux and start to program more and tinker more.
Um, and then it was like, okay, so what have I got accessible to me?
I've got in that.
Okay.
So let's learn everything I can about what it's doing.
And, um, so it's, I guess it's sort of the, the interest, um, if something picks my interest on rabbit hole down there and we'll just stay there for months if I can.
That's so funny.
I do the same thing when I'm like, whenever I'm in like a situation where I don't have many options for what I could be doing.
I think a great example is when I'm sitting on a plane, I'll start to do things that I don't normally do.
So I'll like read a book or I'll like, or I'll like start to just like read through man pages or stuff.
Like, like I'll just do like things that are like, you know, they consume time, but it's not necessarily the most interesting thing because I'm in this restricted sort of environment.
And I feel like that's like the perfect intersection of like interest and opportunity breeds, you know, knowledge or information or however you want to, you want to build that equation.
Yeah.
God forbid you pay that 12 99 for the internet on the flight so that you can answer emails or write tweets or whatever.
On the eight hour flight.
Yeah.
Exactly.
I mean, I remember quite vividly literally sitting in a data center, no internet access.
And the particular customer I was working for wanted us to leave our hard drives when we were done with the job.
And it was kind of a four week job.
And I was like, well, what am I going to do with my time?
Because it was literally scanning.
Mm hmm.
So I was like, well, I enjoy programming, so I'll just program something.
And it was actually quite liberating writing this, writing this whole thing, knowing it was going to get thrown in the bin in a couple of weeks time and I couldn't take it with me.
Ah, nice.
And that, that was, that was programming purely for the, for the joy and, and the challenge.
Wow.
Nice.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
That, that is how, that is how growth happens.
You know, when you're, when you're doing it for, like you were saying for the joy of programming for the passion of it.
Um, but so, you know, this was an in, going back to your, your experience at Yahoo and Oath, this is a, this is a red team, um, sort of role.
And as I understand, well, uh, my personal experience.
So anecdotally is that when I was doing internal pen tests, I wasn't doing a lot of, which is different than red team, but, you know, uh, correlated in some way.
Um, I wasn't doing a lot of exploitation or exploit development.
I was doing a lot of pivoting around in the internal network.
I was doing a lot of escalating of privileges inside the network in order to weave my way through.
Right.
Um, so I'm wondering, you know, how different that was at, at Yahoo internal red team.
Um, or if that skillset was developed elsewhere.
Yeah.
So it was pretty similar in terms of the pivoting and you kind of spend probably 70% of your time on post exploitation.
Right.
Um, and that, that was always the kind of prove, prove what you can do.
You, you've exploited the system now prove what you can do with that.
Right.
Um, but there was the kind of 30% of initial, initial access, which was pretty, pretty fun exploitation.
Um, I remember, I think I'm sure it's fine to say this.
Um, my, my first week there, I wasn't set up properly and was just given the standard laptop.
Um, so no, no, no more privileges than anybody else would have.
And by the end of the week, I had a remote code execution on Yahoo laptops.
Oh yeah.
Well, that's another one of those scenarios where you've got like limited, you know, limited scenarios and you just kind of got to work within your environment, which is such a hacker mentality thing in general as well, because our whole, our whole job is to take, you know, that, that data center with no internet, that laptop, you know, that.
That, uh, injection point where you can't use special characters and figure out a way to, to break out of those constraints and, and get access to, you know, greater privileges.
So I think, you know, I'm sure there, it was applicable in so many ways, but even just from a mentality perspective, that'll help you grow as a hacker and build that sort of mental resiliency.
You need to be able to push through almost any situation you're put in from a technical perspective.
Yeah.
Kind of.
They went back into the office.
It was.
The kind of.
Period where it was off was very much about self care and looking after my wife and family.
!
Mm.
And I realized I just wasn't wasn't ready to go back to work.
And I didn't want to put HackerOne in position of having somebody on salary who wasn't
doing any work.
So I kind of spoke to my team there and said, really appreciate everything.
But I'm going to step back.
Mm.
So was that day one of full time bug money after that?
Not day one.
I took a few months, few more months and then kind of realized I do need to start earning
money.
Mm.
And that's where I thought, yeah, I should kind of pull my finger out and get starting.
So I think it was like April.
Mm.
Yeah, I think it coincided with the UK tax year.
So April 6th or something.
I was like, right, let's do this.
Give this a go and see where we go.
Mm.
So you've been your transition into your transition into bug bounty was a little bit.
Their full time bug bounty was a little bit more strained than most people's.
I think that, you know, we we've kind of talked in the past before about being in a full time
bug bounty position and and and the kind of mental stress that that puts on somebody.
Um, and normally I think you and I both agree that it's not prudent to go into that position
without, you know, a decent financial runway and a decent, um, or at least from our my conversation,
uh, you know, a decent, um, home life set up and stuff like that.
Um, but that, that, that transition actually happened a little bit different for you.
So did, um, you know, what were the first couple months?
Obviously you were dealing with a lot of personal things as well, but from a work perspective,
um, did you, did you find it hard to, to focus or, or were you kind of ready to get back into
it after having taken, um, an appropriate amount of time to, you know, grieve and such,
even though that, you know, an appropriate amount can never be, be taken enough for you to, to, to get back into it.
Yes. So it was, I mean, I've been working in security as I say for, would have been 12 years or something by that point.
Um, so security is a relatively well-paid industry.
So I, I did have the financial backing to, um, so you have to do it without risk.
And my wife was going back to work around the same time as well.
And she's a, uh, a management consultant.
So again, a relatively well-paid, um, uh, job there.
So with the, with the two incomes and the money we had in the bank, it was, wasn't as much of a, of a risk.
Sure. Um, I, I think I said to myself, I'll give it three months before I reassess, see, see how we get on.
Um, and if I need to get another job at the end of that, then I would start to look.
But, um, that was four and a half years ago.
I haven't looked back.
So had you been thinking about doing full-time bug bounty or anything prior to that, or was it kind of just like in the, in that time of your life, you were just analyzing sort of the available options, things that you'd been doing.
And it was kind of a logical step to just give it a shot and see what happens.
Or had you kind of been toying with that in the back of your mind that, you know, I, I like bug bounty.
I'm very involved in bug bounty, obviously working at hacker one and doing Yahoo bug bounty program before that.
You're, you know, very in the scene, you're very in the know your, your mind is kind of in the right place.
And was it kind of just like that natural progression or, or was this something that had always been in the back of your mind for, you know, for a while?
Yeah. So I was working at hacker one.
I was still hacking on, obviously on programs that I wasn't managing.
Um, and I, I was using that as my kind of technical outlet whilst doing less technical work, um, at hacker one.
Um, I think without, I think it's not difficult to say without how, how things could have been different.
Um, I, I very much believe in hacker one and their kind of vision.
So I, I could see that I would have stayed with them, um, whilst keeping on hacking in the, in the background.
Um, but difficult to say.
Um, did you experience a lot of challenges with that balance of like TPM and hacker?
Cause I, I've heard a lot of on both sides of it of like, you know, whether it's being a triage or whether it's working adjacent to triage or doing TPM or whatever at hacker one.
And also trying to do the, the hacking.
And you mentioned that there are certain programs you can't hack on and that kind of stuff.
Did you find that to be a real big hindrance that made you excited to no longer be working there?
Or was it kind of just like, you know, if you were still working there, that's fine.
You could have gotten around it and, and, and figured out how to hack outside of that.
Yeah.
I, I don't think it was too much of a hindrance.
Um, I wasn't working on any of the, I think it was only one or two programs that I was working on.
I personally would have had a huge amount of interest in hacking.
Uh, and there are obviously a lot of programs available.
So I don't think it would have been too bad.
The, the bigger thing would have been the, the time and the, um, and the energy.
Um, so obviously working for what's primarily an American company, um, on UK hours, you kind of have to be a lot more flexible with your, with your time to fit in meetings with, with the States.
Um, certainly West coast.
Um, so kind of end up working later in the evenings, which is when at the time I would have been hacking.
So, uh, for example, it's 9 30, it's 9 30 AM here in California.
Yeah.
And I imagine it's probably five or 6 PM in the UK.
It's yeah.
Half five.
So yeah.
What does that mean?
Is that 5 30?
5 30.
Since it's half five by this point.
That's one of my favorite UK expressions because it's for Americans, it's extremely ambiguous as to what that means.
Meanwhile, we say like quarter to quarter after.
Yeah.
In, uh, in Europe as well.
In, in German, it would be, uh, half six.
Cause I do half two and we do half past.
Oh, wow.
No way.
Really?
Yeah.
That's the worst.
Um, wow.
So, so, you know, bring, bring it back to, you know, this new, this new stage of life you're in with, with full-time bug bounty.
You've been, I started in March of 2020 full-time bug bounty and you started in April of 2019.
So you've got a year, a year on me.
And there, there are, are very few people I'll say that have been able to, um, sustain long-term full-time bug bounty.
Yasin has done a great job of it.
You've done a good job of it.
Um, you know, people, but people often have a hard time with burnout and with, um, I guess just the mental stress that comes along with it, even though their earnings might be, might be good.
Um, so do you have any tips or tricks for people that are looking to get into full-time bug bounty and how to, um, survive the, the mental tolls of that?
Yeah.
I mean, the first one is get your finances in order.
Um, I have a lot of people who've come to me and speak, speak to me about full-time bug hunting.
Uh, I think I wrote something on it, uh, in 2020 maybe.
Um, and off the back of that, I've had a lot of conversations, but it's always make sure your finances in order is the first thing.
Um, it was a very low risk move for me because my previous experience and connections, I was pretty certain I could get a job quickly if I needed to.
Um, I also had, as I said, over a decade of technical professional experience in security.
So I knew what I was doing and familiarity with HackerOne and some other, um, bug bounty programs.
So for, for people who want to get into it, first thing is just minimize your risk.
Make sure you've got enough money in the bank.
If you've got a bad run of things, that could be easily three months.
Easily.
Have a bad run of things.
Um, so if you're bug hunting to pay your next rent bill, that's, that's not a good position to be in.
Um, and then on the kind of burnout side of things, for me personally, I work, well, when I, when I am working, it's just ramping back up again.
Now, um, I work about three days a week.
Um, and I'm relatively strict with that.
Cause I, um, do childcare the other, the other couple of days, um, while my wife works.
Um, and that gives me a lot of time away from the computer.
So with my family, with my kids, um, which, which certainly helps.
And I try to only hack on programs that I enjoy.
Um, I know I could make more money if I were to hack on things that didn't interest me, but I'm disciplined enough to say, I want, I want to do this.
And I want to feel the joy of, of doing this.
Um, if I sit down at my, on my computer and dread what I'm doing that day, that's not where I want to be.
Hmm.
And that's one of the big reasons I've not looked to go back into full-time work is I enjoy what I do.
And I set the, I set the direction for what I do on a daily basis and, and on the long-term as well.
Um, giving somebody else that power again, I would find very difficult.
Yeah, no, absolutely.
And I, I think that's something that, yeah, I, I am beginning to learn for myself now as well is like, even when I'm in a job, I'm in a job.
Um, even though I have the freedom to work less hours and, and, you know, certainly I, I do take more time off than I would be allowed if I were working, uh, you know, in, in an industry, you know, if I had a traditional job.
Um, but, um, the ability to say, all right, I'm actually going to work four days a week, or I'm going to work three days a week.
Um, is something that as weird as it sounds, I haven't really considered up until this point.
Um, uh, especially with the other ventures that I have going on it, sometimes it works out that way, but it, you know, it's four days of hacking, one day of real estate, you know, three days of hacking, one day of training, one day of real estate or whatever.
Right. And so I think that's something that going into this next phase for me, um, in 2024, I kind of want to set the goal of trying to cut my work hours down to, you know, um, to four days a week, or maybe even three, uh, under your, under your, uh, example here.
Um, and I think that will actually help a lot with, with lifestyle balance because it is really easy to, to get hyper focused on bug bounty and to, um, you know, burn out on it really quickly.
So yeah, that, that aspect of taking a break and, and having that built into your schedule, um, I think is very powerful.
Yeah.
And it's the flexibility as well.
So if you're having a bad day, just being able to say, no, I'm done.
Yeah.
Just, just walking away.
And I, I'm stubborn as shit about that.
You know, like if I'm having a bad day, I'm like, no, the bad days are where, you know, your true character is defined, you know?
And, and I just try to push through it.
And my wife is like, you idiot.
Like if you're having a bad day and you have the total flexibility to take it off, why would you work in an environment where you're like unhappy, uninterested burnout?
Like, why would you do that?
Like, this is in a terribly inefficient and she's so right.
Um, and so that's such a great lesson and I'm glad to see that that's been producing, you know, results for you as well.
Yeah, no, certainly the, the flexibility is, that's something that I, I really value.
So I can work normal working hours or I can work at 10 PM through to 3 AM if I need to, or just take a day off and work on the, on the weekend when everybody else has taken a day off.
So you get to do everything that's, so you get to like, if you want to go do something, do it on a Wednesday, cause nobody goes out on Wednesdays.
Right.
Yeah.
Then just work on a Saturday.
So you don't have to compete with other people.
That's the other great thing, man, especially for people that like to travel is like, you can make that happen in the middle of the week.
Right.
Especially, especially if your partner can make it happen as well.
It's so awesome to be able to just like show up to these sightseeing places and there's no one there, you know, at, you know, 2 PM on a Tuesday, you know?
Um, and so, yeah, what a, what a great benefit that is as well.
Yeah.
Sorry, I'm hoping we can shift.
Go ahead, Joel.
I walked out of the room, but I wanted to ask, so when you do work like three, three days a week or something, do you find that your workload sort of compensates back for a five day work week?
So say you're working for 40 hours a week, eight hours a day, five days a week.
Um, do you find that you're working like 12, 13, 14 hours on those three days?
Uh, I wish I could sometimes, but no, cause cause you got the, uh, I've got young kids.
It's very much Sundays.
It will be at one, 1 PM.
My wife needs to be online to do work.
So that's my hard deadline.
I'll take that.
Get the kids get on the park and that's it.
Me, me done for that.
I can pick it up maybe when they go to bed, if there's something I'm right in the middle of, but, um, it is relatively strict to three days a week, unless I want to kind of stay up late, uh, in evenings and some evenings.
They will do that.
Nice.
How do you, how do you organize when you have like, you know, you're like working four hours dip for three hours?
Come back work for three hours, leave hacker to it.
Do you, that was my next question.
How do you, how do you do that?
Yeah.
Badly.
I think.
I'm getting better at note taking.
Um, and that's, that's kind of been a big push this past, uh, past couple of years.
Um, so I keep everything in, um, GitLab.
So I use, I actually use project issue tracking for kind of leads, potential bugs, things on the lookout and have it all in there.
I'll write my whole reports in, uh, in there and, and sign them off and then copy them into, uh, into the platform.
Um, and I found that works quite well.
Cause it also lets me, if I am away from the laptop and I have a really good idea, I can just jump on to GitLab open a new issue or a comment to an issue that I'm working on.
Um, and that that's been working relatively well.
Um, I've let it lapse a little bit recently because I haven't been working so much.
Um, but I need to get back into that kind of discipline.
That's such a developer centric approach.
I love that.
I think it's, uh, it's funny because I generally like, I think a lot of developers, but myself, especially I'm very like in favor of running it yourself and like doing all that kind of stuff.
But this is one of those cases where a cloud service or any type of like hosted, whatever is so, so useful because I did the same thing with like notion for my, that's what I use for my notes.
Where if I have something come up and I just am out on the street or I'm traveling or whatever.
And I just think of something, I can pull my phone out.
I can open the app.
I can jot it down in the notes.
And then later when I'm in a position to be hacking, I can open up my notion and I can go through and I can see the notes that I'd left myself.
And it's so, so useful to have just that instant being able to just write it down and then access it later where, you know, if you you're hosting it yourself, you might be able to do that, but it's, it's a lot more difficult and there's more loops.
You got to jump, jump through and all that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
You know, what's kind of odd to me is that a lot of the things that you're talking about there, they seem really developer-y for lack of a better word, but you're, you've never been a developer.
Is that, is that accurate?
Not professionally, no.
Yeah.
So your whole, your whole career has been, you know, security.
But there are a lot of, a lot of correlations, which I think is, is very interesting and is probably sort of a, I imagine is a mindset just sort of base for you as far as that goes.
Yeah.
And it's a discipline thing as well.
I have the worst memory in the world.
So if I don't write it down, I'll remember it in like six days time when it's no use to me.
So I, I do have to do that.
And it, I also find if I'm, if I don't write it down, I'll hyper fixate on it as well.
Yeah.
Whereas if I write it down, I can put it, put it to one side and focus on what I'm doing.
I've joked a couple of times in the past that I've found more bugs whilst lying awake in bed than I do at the, at the computer.
Yeah.
But if I don't write it down at that point, I just won't sleep.
There's not a hoover now.
That's, that's, I think that's a great tip for anyone who needs to have a work life balance with bug bounty.
You know, if you're, if you're a single guy and you're just like really just trying to like fricking love the bug bounty.
And I remember sitting, you know, before I was married and doing some hacking and I would just hack for super long sprints.
And I was just always in the zone and the flow, go, go, go.
But as, as I've, you know, realized the importance of work life balance and, and, you know, maintaining my other relationships, um, the ability to step away from the computer and not lose a bunch of, um, you know, obviously you're going to lose your mental context for sure.
But before you can do that, if you can predict by, you know, setting a timer or whatever, you know, for five minutes or 10 minutes before you have to leave writing down where you're at currently.
And then being able to come back to that.
I found it's a lot easier to get back in that flow state, um, when you return to it.
Uh, and, and it seems like that's what, what you've been thinking as well with, with sort of trying to get back into taking notes.
Yeah, hugely. Um, kind of my, my next step and progression on that this next year is to really flesh out, um, methodologies for myself.
Mm. Mm.
So I, a lot of my bug hunting is very, either very ad hoc or I get a particular, I find a particular type of bug and then look around for pro for that bug on different programs.
Um, I'm just, I'm not a very good, like if you sit me down in front of a web app, I'll get bored in three seconds.
Mm.
Um, but if I've got a methodology, I know I can follow and, and that can help me pick out interesting things to look at.
Um, I think that will really help me.
And then if I get some source code, um, rather than just looking for, I, again, I hyper fixate on code execution.
Um, cause that's the real big, big bug, but there are hundreds of bugs.
I don't even bother looking for, which are really big impacts.
So I'm, I'm going to, my, my goal for kind of 23, 24 is from train myself and really, um, formalize a lot of the things that I'm doing.
Mm. Yeah.
So that's, that's a great segue right into your, your, um, you know, bug bounty hunting methodology.
Joel, did you have something you wanted to add before we moved to that?
Well, I was just gonna say that that's something that happens.
I think I, I certainly experienced a lot where it's like the things that I look for is like a sliding window or over time, as I find new stuff that I find really interesting or new techniques or whatever, like that's what I'm really looking for.
Like when I'm present and hacking and things that I would look for even like six months ago or a year ago are just not as interesting or not as important or not really what, like I might look for it if I happen to see something and be like, oh yeah, let me check for that.
Yeah.
I'll be pivoting into like different exploitation techniques specifically and, and exclusively as I, as I progress and I'll, and I'll just like kind of shift the things that I look for over time, instead of looking at every single thing that I've ever looked at ever in my entire history of hacking.
Um, do you, how do you like manage that?
Do you keep like notes of, you know, different categories or, um, there's a site we've talked about hack tricks.
That's kind of like this, where there's different categories for like XSS, what you could do in XYZ scenario.
Like, do you have anything like that?
Uh, I have in the past, um, and I, I've lost several versions of it.
Um, I am trying to build it up again for, again, it's for bugs that interest me.
And that, that's the key thing.
I never want to be looking for every bug because that's going back toward it and that's not what interests me.
Um, but I personally find XSS really quite, quite boring to look for.
The only time I ever look for it is if I need an XSS to trigger an RCE or something like that.
Right.
Um, actually I was talking to somebody the other day, so I've, I've only found one SQL injection bug in my bug,
bug bounty career.
And I was using that to trigger another more, uh, better bug.
And, um, that's great.
I love that.
Yeah.
They're just not bugs that interest me because the fix is input elevation or, or output encoding.
And it's just not an interesting thing.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
So it sounds like generally nice.
Yeah.
So when you're hacking, like you're not looking at the mediums and that stuff, like what, what,
what are you generally submitting?
Is it pretty much highs and crits and very selective?
Like, I think like Justin and I have a slightly different methodology on this generally.
Like I'm very pick and choose about what I want to submit.
I only really want to submit like super high quality, super high impact as higher crit as I can get type vulnerabilities.
And Justin views it more as like a volume is also important, especially when you do it full time.
And so having a flow of mediums, maybe not lows, but mediums especially is like really important to keep a regular flow of income.
And then working on those highs and crits is also obviously important just for big bonuses and all that kind of stuff.
Dude, I'll, I'll report a low.
I don't, I don't give a shit.
Okay.
Yeah.
No, it's all on table, I guess.
No, just, just, just, sorry.
Yeah.
Continue Alex.
Sorry.
Yeah.
So I, I definitely aim for the, for the highest and the crits.
I think my, my target is kind of around one or two higher crit a month on kind of bigger paying programs.
Hmm.
And that, that normally tides me over.
I was, yeah, I was looking at, I wrote this down somewhere in four and a half years, I've submitted under 200 bugs on that one.
Yeah.
So I, I do go for very much for, for fewer and higher impact issues where I can.
That kind of changes a little bit if we're talking about life hacking events and then pretty much medium plus or we'll go for those.
Yeah.
Again, I, I don't like taking the time to report those.
I, I often find reporting low issues is detrimental to spending the time on finding other issues.
Yeah.
So on the topic of.
That makes sense.
I just ran the numbers on that.
It's, it's a, that's four, that's four vulnerabilities per month on average.
It seems.
That's pretty good.
Which is pretty.
One a week.
That that's yeah.
That is.
That impact is just like.
High quality.
You've got to be pushing out.
Yeah.
So on the topic of.
It is.
And so.
How does that change like your hacking flow?
Do you, do you pretty much only do live hacking event prep or how much are you doing?
Typical standard program hacking versus jumping to LHE's?
Um, so I kind of have a, a kind of all or nothing on, on life hacking events.
And that's, um, not just effort.
That's performance as well.
Um, I've bombed in so many live hacking events, like only being able to report kind of one or
two mega bugs.
Um, and I feel, kind of feel like a necessity at that time.
Mm.
Um, or I get one or two or three really high impact bugs.
Right.
Um, and that, that, so my, my normal focus is kind of there, but it's a bit more muted.
If I can get one really high impact bug in the live hacking event, I'm happy.
Um, and then I'll, I'll work around, uh, work around that.
Um, and again, that also depends on who's running it as well.
If I'm really engaged with the, with the customer.
Uh, and I think Justin mentioned earlier, uh, GitHub was a good example of that last year.
Uh, as soon as they were announced as the customer, as soon as they were announced as
the customer, I went all in on GitHub.
Mm.
So the normal life hacking event period is about two weeks of hacking.
Once you know the full scope of the life hack event, but as soon as the customer was announced
it was all right.
Okay.
All in.
So I think I had about four and a half, nearly five weeks of packing on them.
Mm.
And that paid off hugely.
Wow.
For that event.
Yeah.
That's, that's awesome, man.
And, and yeah, I, I remember the majesty of that, that performance, uh, that will always
be concreted in my mind, uh, as one of the greatest live hacking event performances I've ever seen.
So congrats on that.
And, and, and in conjunction with that, I, I wanna, I wanna talk a little bit about,
um, your, your bug hunting techniques.
Uh, but also, you know, let's look at specifically for live hacking events.
So, you know, you mentioned that you're focusing on high and critical bugs and on, and live hacking
events, you don't get to pick your target.
Right.
Which I understand you're normally pretty picky about because you have a specific set of, um,
of, uh, a very particular set of skills, uh, that.
I was gonna say if you weren't.
Yeah, exactly.
That you, that you are gonna use to, to hunt down the, the high and critical bugs.
Um, but that apply less well to other areas just by nature of, of how that is.
So, um, when you're going, can you explain to me a little bit about what kind of areas you're looking at?
Uh, if there's any indicators to you of what might be interesting for these higher and critical bugs?
Cause a lot of people are stuck in the area where they, they're finding, you know, um, mediums, lows,
and the occasional high, but the crit is very elusive and you're one of the people that consistently
finds crits.
Um, so could you talk a little bit about that?
Yeah.
So, I mean, the first thing I'll look for is any kind of source code or, or desktop application
that's in scope, um, or when I think I mentioned earlier, where they're using kind of open source
modules that, that I can access the source on.
Um, that's my, my comfort zone.
Um, so as soon as I see something like that, I'll, I'll dive into it head first.
Normally if you see a desktop application in scope of five bounty program, it'll be, uh, um,
electron or, or chromium embedded framework, um, applications.
So you can pretty much get the source out of them easily as well to go through.
Um, and then it's anything that kind of hits my, uh, I guess spidey sense of, of where an issue is.
So any PDF rendering, any HTML rendering, um, I'll always spend time there.
So I had a very productive kind of six months in the last year, um, looking at, uh, headless
browser exploitation.
Mm-hmm.
Um, so that was kind of kicked off with H1702 last year, I think.
Yeah.
In Vegas.
Yes, it was.
There was, uh, one target I was looking at that, that had, um, was using headless
Chrome to, uh, to render some, some, actually it wasn't user input.
I, that's, this is one case where I did have to find a cross-site scripting.
Mm-hmm.
Um, but I, I saw they were using an old version.
So it was like, huh, I do wonder if I could write an exploit for that.
I've not, not written one for Chrome before, but let's see what I can do.
So why not try and write a Chrome exploit under pressure in a few days?
Cause, cause that sounds like fun.
Right.
Um, but I, I was lucky enough.
There was, um, enough information out there on this old version, um, at the time to, to cobble
something together, um, and did very well with that bug.
Mm.
Um, yeah.
And that kind of gave me the, well, I, for that sort of.
I, I was gonna say, you know, on, on that note, I'm sorry to interrupt.
Um, but you know, at that time that was really, that was something really impressive that we had, that not a lot of us had seen, uh, at the bug bounty scene.
Cause you know, you do see a lot of this stuff in sort of more of the pwn to own or like just actual, just people that hunt for zero days, uh, and don't do the competitions.
Um, you know, you seen those there, but that, that sort of browser exploitation wasn't something we had done.
I'd seen a lot of in the bug bounty scene before.
So could you talk to me a little bit about how you, you went on that path of being, of learning about browser exploitation and, um, how you did it so quickly to be able to write and exploit, uh, for this specific target in, in a couple of days.
That seems like quite a feat.
Yeah.
So, um, I've got, I've got modest experience with binary exploitation anyways.
So I kind of understand all the, um, the principles of, uh, of what you need to do.
So bypassing SLR, uh, what to do when you've got control of the programming counter and all the rest of it.
I kind of get those fundamentals, but, um, I hadn't looked at a full on browser, um, JavaScript exploit before.
Um, the GitHub security blog had some really good, um, posts on it about exploiting very similar issues than the one I was trying to do.
Um, so I started reading up there.
I can't remember the, uh, person's name who's writing these bugs and probably butcher it.
If I did try to try to say it, but really detailed exploitation, um, kind of exploitation steps of how they went about finding and exploiting some bugs.
So that was a really good stepping stone, um, to help me with that.
And it was from that point on when, when I knew it was possible, it was just sheer force of will and no sleep.
I think of that.
Well, okay.
So that's, I'm glad you added that last bit.
Cause I was like in those situations, when I, when I get in that situation, when I lock on, I'm like, I know this is possible.
I got to get it done.
Right.
Then that's when the rubber hits the road for that life balance stuff that I preach about all the time.
That's when I say like, all right, am I going to just brain dump onto this notepad and then go to bed at a decent time with my wife?
Or am I going to, you know, sit here and write code till 3 AM in the morning?
And, and so, I mean, I guess, no, I'm going to put you on the spot.
Like what, what happened that, that during that event?
I mean, what, what did that, that life balance look like for you?
It was relatively good at the start of the event.
I had no bugs and I didn't have any leads.
It was, it was about halfway, halfway through the event.
I came across this target and, and realized it was going to be vulnerable.
And that's where it did kind of take over a bit.
Yeah.
But then you also have the, um, kind of difference in that you're flying away from your family or, or, or your usual, um, routine.
So going out to Vegas, I had eight hours on a flight and a laptop again.
So it's like, right.
Okay.
Let's see what I can do there.
I think by the time I landed, I had most primitives in place that I needed to be able to prove it was vulnerable.
Yeah.
And then from that point on, it was, uh, then trying to write a reliable exploit for the particular version in use.
Um, and really hammering that home.
I remember, I think I, I got it at about, um, 5 AM Vegas time.
I, I finally popped it on the day of that.
It was either the day before or the day of, of that particular customer.
Um,
So was it a full exploit to RCE or was it just like a POC where it crashes or something?
Uh, so full exploit to RCE, um, but with, without a sandbox escape.
Okay.
So a lot, uh, a large portion of the time when you see headless browsers being used, um, in a backend, the sandbox would have been disabled because it's easier to deploy that way.
Um, and that makes exploiting it so much easier.
Um, I've only done one successful full renderer RCE through sandbox escape.
And that was fun.
I'm not interested in doing that again.
If I can avoid it.
Yeah.
So I am curious, like, do you think it's worth it taking that last like couple inches?
Cause I I've reported something very similar.
We got paid for it at a live hacking event.
Um, I think you can say who it was.
It was meta.
It was a hardware device and it was using an outdated chromium browser essentially.
And so what we did was we found a POC for that same version range and it was able to successfully crash it.
But we didn't decide that it was really worth the effort to like push it just that last couple of inches to go from crash.
Definitely valid.
Like could you could take this further to all the way to like full ROC, RCE POC.
Do you think that it's worth it to do that?
Or will the company kind of understand?
And this is kind of company by company, but generally do you think it's, it's worth it to like spend all that time and effort developing a full working POC?
Or is it good enough to say, here's a CBE for the V8 engine.
It applies to this version.
We can see that it crashes with this POC.
You can do connect the dots.
Um, in my experience, every time I haven't had a full RC POC, I've been like, it's been downgraded to a, to a medium.
Or fobbed off.
Um, the recent life hacking event, I, I had one with a, I just submitted POC.
I was like, this would be a Herculean effort to get to RCE.
And they were like, yeah, here's $200.
Oh man.
Yeah.
So.
Oh my gosh.
The, the benefit.
And this is what I really found last year was that once I had one and people learnt that I had one, they would come to me and say, oh, I've got this one over here.
Have you got an exploit for that?
And if I didn't, but I thought there was one that I could again, develop, I would go and I did, would do that.
So I think in the end last year, I wrote three, four Chrome render RCEs.
Um, a Fanson JS RCE and a WK HTML to PDF RCE.
Um, and each one of those got used at least twice.
Um, wow.
In, in collabs as well, which kind of really helped because once it's there, it's no effort for me to say, or very little effort, change the version numbers and some offsets.
Right.
So this is, this is sort of like the, the reverse today is new is like, you know, you go to today is new when you need a sub domain takeover and access on a sub domain or like, you know, like some sort of cookie inject, you know, or some, some lower level bugs that will help you build a greater chain.
And you go to Alex Chapman when you need a crazy, you know, super exploit for your, you know, uh, vulnerable ish looking, uh, browser renderer that's happening.
That's, that's really cool because that model really does.
That model really does work.
We've seen it time and time again, uh, at one of the last live hacking events, Eric took first place without having a single report that was his own.
It was all collaboration, which, which was just absolutely legendary.
And made bug bounty history about what the power of collaboration, you know, has.
Um, so it's cool to see the flip side of that as well with you.
Um, and, and I think that speaks to, uh, your, your experience within collaboration as well, because you, you collaborate a lot with a specific set of people at live hacking events.
And, um, I'm sure that helps the scenarios where, um, you know, you, like you've mentioned your, your bug bounty experience is kind of up and down like that.
Um, so could you talk a little bit about that collaboration experience and how it's helped you, uh, grow as a hunter and also as it's helped your performance in live hacking events?
Yeah.
I mean, it's collaborating in live hacking events is always a lot more fun than doing it on your own anyway.
Um, and that, that's kind of the, one of the things I always fall back on.
I enjoy my job and I want to enjoy my job.
Um, so it's fun to just get, get together with a group of friends and, and go at it.
But also the, uh, the hackers who I've been working with, um, on a few events.
So Archangel, Rezo and DC, um, they all have different areas of interest and, um, and focus than me.
So if I fail to get my one critical, then they've between them, they've got 50 or 60 reports in, um, that we can, uh, profit through.
Um, but if I get my one big bug, then it goes, goes the other way.
So it's, it's been a really good, good way of working for me recently.
Um, certainly in live hacking events.
Hmm.
And I bet that helps as well with your growth as, as a hacker, when it comes to like being able to see other hackers and their style as well.
Cause you mentioned before that you're, you're not as strong in the traditional web vulnerabilities and having someone like, you know,
Archangel and Rezo people that have strong web backgrounds.
Um, and then having access to those reports as well as I'm sure just a great learning opportunity and then vice versa for them being able to see your, your deeply technical source code powered, um, you know, mega crits, uh, I'm sure helps them grow as well.
Yeah.
And then that's kind of part of the thing as well.
If you're not, if you're not learning or doing bug bounty, you're doing something wrong.
It's, um, you can always want to be trying to improve yourself and, and your skill sets and, um, collaboration is one of the easiest ways to, to kickstart that.
Hmm.
Yeah. Yeah. That's really interesting.
Um, so for like the binary exploitation side versus source code review, do you find that you're doing a lot more of the binary exploitation or what, what kind of stuff are you really focusing on now?
Um, I do less binary exploitation, um, than I, than I want.
It's always a lot more involved, uh, and it's got a lot higher costs to, to doing it.
Mm-hmm .
So whilst I would love to have that be my main area of focus, one, I don't think I'm skilled enough in that, in it.
And two, it's not as reliable income as source code review and, and other forms of testing.
So if it was just down to me every other week, I'd be doing binary exploitation and filling in other areas in between.
But, um, I'm not quite their skill level yet.
I don't think.
So we've talked about this a little bit when we talked about source code review, we had a whole episode about it.
But do you, when you do your source code review, is it more of like a sort of outside in approach or an inside out approach?
Meaning do you find interesting, like syncs, like, uh, you know, there's a command being run here.
Or do you say here's a public endpoint that looks like it might have juicy functionality.
Let me see how I can connect these two together.
Um, how do you, how do you sort of approach a code base when you're looking for those really high criticality vulnerabilities?
Yeah.
So I tend to focus on the syncs and then, and then work backwards from there.
So as I said, I kind of hyper-focus on code execution wherever I can.
Mm-hmm .
And be that through, uh, command injection, deserialization, um, writing arbitrary files, that sort of thing.
That's, that always kind of piques my interest and, um, and that's where I spend my, my time.
Um, I over-focus in those areas.
So I know I could be finding a lot more bugs if I, if I looked a bit more generally.
And again, that's kind of one of my, um, goals for this, this next year or two.
Um, but also to bring in more automation into my kind of source code review and binary reverse engineering.
Mm.
So I've been playing around with, uh, CodeQL, Sandra, uh, Yearn, and a few others, um, to, uh, kind of help with that and build up a methodology there.
Yeah.
Where do you draw the line?
That's a, sorry.
Go ahead, Joel.
There's a crazy audio delay.
So it's like, we keep talking over each other.
Where do you like draw the line in terms of when you're, when you're going sort of inside out, right?
Like if you have, uh, something that looks like code execution and you've flushed out sort of what you think are all the paths.
Do you, there's always kind of that possibility that you might be misunderstanding something or there might be a connection somewhere else.
Where do you draw that line and say, okay, it's time to move on and look at the next sink.
Um, normally based on my frustration level, if I feel that I've been hammering on it.
Yeah.
If I've been hammering on it for a couple of days and really can't just can't see any, any future in it, then I'll, I'll try something else.
And probably I'll probably get back to it for a couple of days later on.
So take a break, go back to it.
Um, and then sometimes I'll just outright think no, no way.
No way that's going to be exploitable.
And then somebody like, uh, Vax will come along and exploit the exact same thing that I was looking at.
I hate that man.
I freaking hate it when Vax does that.
He, he did it on one of the GitLab bugs.
Um, exif tool.
Oh, no way.
I checked the logs.
Um, I was looking at it about two weeks before he, he submitted his, his RCE and it was like,
I can see shelling out here, but there's no way to get access to it.
So I'm just going to move on.
And then sort of like, Oh, that's a big bug.
Man, that, that, that stings.
And, and, and I just want to go back to what you were saying before.
Um, when Joel asked about sources and sinks, uh, that we've, we've asked that question a couple of times, we've discussed it ourselves as well.
And I think this is the first time we've had a really solid, like, no, I go to sinks, you know, a sort of response.
Like, um, first, I think that's, I think that's really cool.
And I think that that shows that that methodology is absolutely, um, you know, an, an appropriate methodology and methodology that produces really good results.
Um, and, and I think I tend to be on the, on the flip side of that.
And I, I like to try to go look at the sources, see where I can inject, you know, my input and, and then go down all of the routes, you know, and, and it may be because I, I don't have as good of an, I, a perspective on, um, you know, which, which sinks lead to code execution.
Like I've recently been talking about, um, configuration file injection and, uh, just sort of, if you can inject into a templated, uh, configuration file, right.
That there's a lot of chances for, for RCE there because, um, you know, there's this switch of context between your, your current service and then the service that it's, it's building with that configuration file.
Yeah.
Um, and so I think maybe as maybe in the beginning, it might be helpful for people to look at sources.
And then as they gain more experience, they should look at sinks.
Would you, would you agree with that?
Yeah.
I mean, uh, it's really different, different approaches for different people.
I, I know what I'm looking for when I'm looking, um, at a source repository.
Um, again, sometimes to my detriment, cause I will, I will focus on it.
Um, but I've had two recent examples.
I've been doing quite a lot of work on JDBC, um, drivers recently.
Um, so looking at what can be done with them.
And there were two JDBC drivers I found out there that I was able to find had, um, Archie file read, right.
Um, so that if you, you can get this to connect to a server, the server just read anything off your, off the connecting system.
Wow.
Um, and that was, I found those specifically because I was looking for the particular file rights, um, and other things.
And then work back from there, working at the protocol stack and being right.
Can I access this?
Okay.
Yep.
So if I implement a custom Diffie-Hellman exchange, I can get through to this bit.
So working backwards really helps me rather than working from the input.
Yeah.
Um, I, I think this is something that I've actually seen, and this actually goes to a bug that I want to talk about later, which is our, our bug collision.
We had at a live hacking event earlier this year.
So I'm, forgive me for that.
Um, and, and we'll get to that, but I, I want to, I want to talk about this whole concept of, you know, having a protocol connect and, and then have that, you know, reverse connection back to the client have, have some, have some effect on the client.
But you piqued my interest when you talked about those connection pieces.
So anything, uh, you know, anything you want to share any little tidbits that you want to throw out there with regards to that?
I mean, yeah, generally the security boundary when a client connects to a server is less than when a server connects to, talks back to a client.
Does that make sense?
Right.
So there's a lot of programs assume that the client will only ever use in an authorized way, um, to connect to an authorized server.
Whereas if you can, um, get a client to connect to a server you control, you generally have a much more privileged, um, access to be able to do, to do things.
And I'm alluding to the bug that, that, that, I know Justin wants to talk about, but, um, I found that exact same bug in four or five different client applications.
Um, because the original developers thought nobody's ever going to stick this on a server and connect to an untrusted server.
Right.
Or stick it in the backend and connect to an untrusted server.
And then kind of cloud CI CD comes along and we're all using Git and SVN and Mercurial and Perforce and, and other things to connect to untrusted servers.
Um, and then similar with, um, kind of low code, uh, low code environments.
Okay.
Let's let the, uh, the customers connect to their own databases.
So here, just give us a database connection string and we'll go connect to your, your database and pull the data from you.
Um, and then a lot of the clients just weren't designed with that security boundary.
Yeah.
So it's really interesting, um, place to be looking for bugs.
And again, it kind of fits my, if it's a client, you can normally get hold of the software.
You can reverse engineer it or look it up on GitHub.
So, so I'll, I'll, uh, that, that definitely is a excellent tip for anyone looking for high impact bugs there.
If there's a database connection that is being sent from the server to your database or something of the like, great stuff there.
But I want to, I want to go back to that JDBC piece that you said, you know, uh, so let's say I've got a JDBC configuration, uh, injection, right.
Where I, where I can have it connecting out to my DB.
Um, you know, I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna prevent you from sharing your, your research here, but, uh, any, any specific directions you want to point us in or are, are we looking for a blog post in the future?
Or is this gonna, are we keeping our cards close to our chest on this one?
Yeah.
I mean, I'm still actively exploiting a few of these issues.
Okay.
So keep a little bit there.
Well, Hey, the audience can't tell me I didn't try cause I tried for you audience.
So.
Well, I think generally if you can change the, um, query string parameters on a JDBC, or if you can control this query string, uh, uh, parameters on the JDBC connection, you can do quite a lot.
Um, a few of the connectors are getting better.
So, uh, I think the, which was it, uh, not DB2.
One of the, the, not, not MarioDB, MySQL or DB2, um, namescapes me, but they, they've had two CDs raised against them recently for this kind of exact same issue.
And one was being able to specify the location of a log file, um, through a query string parameter, which meant you could write arbitrary, uh, bar output out.
Uh, and another one was a JN, a JNDI injection, which was similar to the, um, log4j.
Interesting.
Um, exploitation.
Very cool.
Was the, was the log4j what kind of led you down this whole rabbit hole of looking at JDBC or?
Uh, no, I actually picked this up a few years before that came out.
And then, um, when that came out again, it kind of led me down that path, path again.
So, um, nice.
Yeah.
He was an early, an early, uh, early adopter with those sort of roles.
Yeah, man.
I was gonna say, if, if I'd had log4j, that would have been, uh, that would have been a good payday.
Yeah.
A lot of near misses here, Alex.
Like, come on, man.
I need to start hanging around Alex more.
Um, just everything that Alex does now, I'm gonna write that down.
Yeah.
Write that down right away.
Um, uh, so I think, uh, we're, we're running to a close here on, on time, but, um, I did
want to talk about, uh, this, this, this bug, and I think, uh, it's enough in the past now
that we can kind of, um, that we can kind of talk about it a little bit.
Uh, this, this was a bug at a live hacking event, um, earlier this year, and it was a RCE
that, and this is the thing that I'm gonna do.
And, and this is the thing that makes me sad too, is that, um, this is a blog post that
Alex wrote up on, on a specific vulnerability and a specific protocol, uh, Perforce.
And, um, and I, you know, using, to be fair to myself, using other resources and Alex's
blog, um, I found, uh, you know, an RCE on this, on this target, the shared target that
we had.
And, um, and then, uh, I submitted the report before Alex did.
Yeah.
So he duped, he duped, and we split the bounty, right?
It's a live hacking event dupe.
But, um, uh, you know, it was one, it was a really, um, great example of the way that
Alex, Alex thinks.
And, and, and what we were talking about earlier with blogging about things that you're passionate
about.
Um, and a perfect example of this client server trust, um, sort of situation that we have,
because that's where the vuln was.
Um, but, and Alex, I don't recall whether I sent you this specific vulnerability before
we started, uh, recording the podcast.
Do you want to talk to the technical details of this vuln?
Uh, did you, do you have the, it fresh enough in your mind or do you want me to take a stab
at it and you can kind of supplement?
Yeah.
I think I've, um, I've actually been looking at it again recently for something else.
So it is top of mind.
Oh, what?
Okay.
All right.
It's, yeah, exactly.
Talk us through it, man.
Talk us through it.
This is an interesting one.
Let's, again, so for, for those who don't know, Perforce is a, uh, version control system.
So similar to Git or, um, SVN that's heavily used in the gaming industry.
Cause it's, it works really well with very large files.
Um, so if you have really large assets, 3d models, that sort of thing.
Um, and it, it, it's a very typical example of the, uh, the client trust that we mentioned
before.
So all the, um, Perforce client really does is connect to the server and the server then
says, run this command.
And then, so the server will say, okay, show me what files you've got.
Check the hashes of the files against the files I've got.
So rather than it being client controlled, it's server controlled.
Um, and that, that was the first thing that kind of got my interest.
I was like, well, how does it do?
How does it give you new files that you don't have on your system?
And it turns out it just sends a, uh, I think the command is literally send file.
Yeah.
Or, um, or write file.
Client dash write file is what I have in my report right here, which is just gold.
Like I love that.
That sounds interesting.
Yeah.
Um, so then seeing that like, okay, right.
How, how are we going to go about, about testing this?
So what do you do?
Break out Python and then start trying to reverse engineer the protocol as it's going on the wire
and wire shark and building up bite by bite, bit by bit, uh, to a point where pretty much
had a fully functioning, um, peripheral server written in Python, um, to kind of handle the
auth, do all the rest of it to get it to the point, um, where we just a login, it would be
able to write an arbitrary file on the, um, on the connecting system.
Hmm.
And that was great.
So then I think just in saying this, this bug collision on the, uh, life hacking event, I, I kind of have a bit of a blasé attitude to submitting these bugs.
I don't think anybody else is going to submit in life hacking events.
Uh, and this one, I wasn't going to submit in the due period.
I was like, nobody's going to find that.
Oh, dude.
Oh, that would have been a nightmare, man.
I'll prove it after the due period closes, uh, because nobody else will find it.
And it's like, oh, I've got a little bit of time.
I'll, I'll get it in.
Holy moly.
I mean, when I found out it'd been juped, it was like, oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm going to start submitting everything.
That's still the fact that's.
Yeah.
Right.
As soon as it was juped, I went to the, uh, tradition.
I was like, um, can you let me know who juped?
Who?
Who was it?
I want to have a word.
It was, it was, um, and, and it was, I want to say on your team as well, they took, you guys
took bets on who it was.
Right.
And, and freak who, who was it that guessed it was me.
One of them correctly guessed that it was me.
Was it?
Yeah.
It might've been Douglas.
I want to say it was Douglas as well.
Yeah.
So I appreciated that vote of confidence.
It is a, uh, one of the highest honors in my bug bounty career to have duped an Alex
Jatman bug.
Um, so I'm sorry for using your own blog post against you, but, um, yeah.
Um, yeah.
I completely forgot.
I'd written that to be honest.
So, uh, you really, no way.
So you didn't even reference back to it when you, when you had, oh my gosh.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Um, and, and so I just wanted to go to what you were saying.
You know, you wrote out a full, a full per force server and I'm looking at my exploit right
now.
And, uh, you know, I, I, I love that experience of writing out, you know, like a binary level
protocol, um, for these sorts of things.
And, you know, you said that handles the auth and stuff like that.
I'm looking at my code and it, you know, handles the auth.
It's just like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't mind that.
You know, like, you know, it connects to the server.
You're like, no, no, no, it's fine.
Yes.
You got it.
Correct.
And then you just, yeah, yes, you're more connected.
Here's the code run.
Um, and it's just, uh, it's just a fun vulnerability type for sure.
Um, so.
That's awesome.
Um, yeah, I think, I think Joel, I think Joel has to bounce to a meeting.
Um, so we'll, we'll bring it to a close here.
Um, Alex, you can, for all of you that are listening, you can find Alex on, on Twitter
at AJX Chapman on HackerOne at AJX Chapman, uh, uh, ajxchapman.github.com.
Everywhere.
AJX Chapman.
Alex, thanks so much for coming on, man.
Did you have anything that you wanted to say as we sign off?
Uh, no, appreciate the, uh, the work you guys are doing on the podcast.
It's, uh, it's a good one.
It's a good one.
I've had to stop listening while I walk the dog there because I've got to take too many
notes.
So, uh, yeah, we, we get that feedback often.
Um, and so we, maybe we need to, uh, stay on top of getting our, our notes out that accompany
the episodes and, uh, and hopefully that'll make for a little bit more of a leisurely listening
experience.
Definitely.
Um, but yeah.
Well, thanks so much again.
And yeah, go ahead, Joel.
Yeah.
No, it was awesome.
I appreciate it.
It was fun and, uh, yeah, yeah.
Well, we'll, we'll, we'll probably be collabing at some point in the future.
Oh yeah, we will.
Sounds good.
Peace.
Cheers.